[Inaudible].
Friends.
If there is one thing that gets on the nerves of the North Korean regime,
and that is capable of unsettling, Kim Jong-un himself,
it is international sanctions because as you probably suspect,
North Korea is one of the countries most severely punished by international
sanctions worldwide,
perhaps the most what's the North Korean regime understands as an economic
blockade by the U S empire against the Jews.
Chase socialist system is in reality,
a joint response by most countries of the world against Pyongyang's nuclear and
ballistic missile program,
a program to which the regime has given the highest priority over the past
decades.
And let's face it developing from scratch the capacity to build nuclear bombs
and manufacture Intercontinental missiles does not exactly come cheap,
especially given the very poor living standards of North Koreans.
But you know how this works,
the needs of the regime are paramount and there are all those patriotic songs to
live up to take a look at the facts.
[Inaudible].
Estimated that the cost of these North Korean military programs has been between
one and $3 billion in the case of the nuclear program and more than $1 billion a
year. In the case of the ballistics program,
to give you an example for the cost of launching a single Intercontinental
missile, along with the launch facilities,
almost 3 million tons of corn could be purchased. And of course,
in a country where people literally Battlestar vation,
this expenditure is alarming.
The fact is that this is the main reason why both the United States and the
United nations security council have been pushing for years for economic and
trade sanctions against North Korea in order to try to persuade the regime to
abandon these military programs. However,
the reality is that apart from the enormous economic damage to the communist
country caused by the sanctions during the last seven years,
the objective of preventing the advance of these programs has not been
fulfilled. So the question we need to ask is why haven't the sanctions worked?
How was it possible that North Korea,
despite being a country that is fenced off backward and subject to all kinds of
sanctions has managed to become a full blown nuclear power? Well, friends,
this is something as simple to answer as it is complex to explain.
[Inaudible].
North Korea has an elaborate and complex mechanism for evading sanctions that
consists of elements as disparate, as bank robbery,
through financial engineering, cyber attacks,
and computer viruses trafficking in precious metals and illegal trade in
international waters among other methods. And if we add to all this,
the umbrella offered by countries like China and Russia,
which although they recognize and accept the sanctions,
do not do much to enforce them. What we find is that in spite of everything,
the North Korean regime has managed to keep its income streams open.
Despite this.
[Inaudible].
Remember, we are talking about the regime itself and not to the country.
Things are different on the national level,
the estimates of the central bank of Korea, that of the South, of course,
estimates that's the North Korean economy has been contracting for at least
three years at closer 5% per year. This is the worst recession since 1997,
but of course the figures are based on estimates,
trade studies and other somewhat abstract analysis because the regime does not
provide any information on actual figures,
All of this however, force North Korea to take action,
which will take effect next January, 2021.
Kim Jong UHIN makes rare admission of economic failure, Korea,
Joan Ong daily,
North Korea to set five-year economic plan at Congress next year,
KCNA Kim Jong una notes that the country had faced unexpected and inevitable
challenges. Nikkei.
Can review, however, even with everything that is going on,
the reality that is despite the Corona virus, economic sanctions,
and almost anything else that happens,
the nuclear and ballistic programs continue in this video,
we will tell you some of the ways in which North Korea has definitely bypassed
both us and UN sanctions and how pressure from the American empire has fallen
way short of having any effect on North Korea's military programs.
What's you about to see is the real world beyond big office politics, listen up.
Are you a sanctioned failing.
Dear friends of visual politic before we dive in and analyze whether or not the
U S sanctions have failed.
There are a couple of things we need to consider the first is that although
North Korea has stopped for the time being it's nuclear tests, it's atomic bomb,
production facilities remain intact.
Also keep in mind that the fact that they no longer perform tests does not
necessarily indicate any particular gesture. Instead,
it could mean that they no longer need to prove anything because they have
already completed this phase of the program. The second we need to know,
even whilst in the middle of talks with the United States and South Korea on
peace and denuclearization,
the communist regime has continued to launch missiles.
For example.
On the 2nd of March, 2020, North Korea launched to short range,
ballistic missiles into the East sea.
This was not unusual because throughout 2019 North Korea launched 25 missiles
and conducted 13 more tests at its facilities.
Therefore the North Korean ballistics program continues to operate at full
capacity. Despite this,
the Trump administration has neither condemned it nor done anything to punish
this type of behavior, which is a clear violation of UN resume.
Butts.
Let's get back to the key question on this video.
How can North Korea finance all these programs if the country,
which is very poor is also subject to very strong international sanctions.
Now this is not a minor question.
The communist country cannot export precious metals or iron or coal or mineral
sands or agriculture products or fish or seafood or textiles,
nor it import machinery vehicles, crude oil,
or refined oil above the limit set by the UN of 500,000 barrels a year.
And these are only just a few examples.
The sanctions literally obstruct North Korea's ability to sell what little it
produces, coal, mineral sands, and textiles. However,
check out this news headline.
North Korea increases illegal coal exports,
satellite images suggest financial times.
Exactly. As we mentioned earlier,
North Korea has developed a complicated system of exports and imports on the
high seas through ship to ship transfers and an extensive network of shell
companies and shady middlemen. These transfers,
which occur in international waters,
or even in Chinese territorial waters allow North Korea to bring in more than
$1 billion each year in order to do this ships with flags and registers that
frequently change are usually used. We are talking about countries like Togo,
Tanzania, Sierra Leone,
or even Panama since these countries do not register or have very lax control
systems of their fleets. More importantly,
this practice circumvents the ban on ship to ship transfers with North Korean
flag vessels established by UN security council resolution 2375,
but stay tuned because North Korea is income. Doesn't stop at Kohl's.
We also exports mineral sands to companies in China with total impunity also by
the way of ship to ship transfers in 2019 alone,
at least $22 million worth of this sand was sold to Chinese companies.
These sands are mainly used for construction and in 2019,
the center for advanced defense studies detected a sharp increase in shipping
activity, extracting Sams on the coast of Haikou.
Right.
But more than 100 ships flying,
the Chinese flag were detected sailing in the vicinity off the hydro mining
site.
The activity, and had you demonstrate scale and a level of sophistication.
Unlike other known cases of North Korean sanctions of Asian at seed providing
renewed evidence of the DPRK is evolving abilities to coordinate and execute
complex operations with facilitators abroad, C4, ADSL report.
That's not even the full extent of North Korea's revenues outside of the
sanction.
Maria also has an entire army of overseas workers,
especially in China who send foreign currency back to North Korea through a
complex financial network that includes tax havens.
Although the UN forced these workers to be repatriated back to North Korea.
The truth is that a good number of the 100,000 workers in 2017 are still working
in China and Southeast Asia.
And we're not talking about a minor issue to give you an idea of the money that
arrives in North Korea from this activity alone that's year 2017,
the communist regime received around $2 billion in the form of remittances and
artificially exorbitant taxes.
So exactly how does all that money get to North Korea? Well,
part of the answer can be found here in.
This research,
us indicts North Koreans accused state state-owned bank of evading sanctions
Reuters.
The investigation into this case concluded that North Korea's foreign trade bank
employed at least 250 shell companies to make payments to the government worth
$2.5 billion. In fact,
the transfers came from countries as disparate and of dubious transparency as
China, Russia, Libya, and Thailand. No surprise.
That.
North Korea has a huge state owned chain of restaurants. Yes,
restaurants with about 125 branches scattered around the world today.
It is not known how many of them are still open.
Although there is evidence that there are several dozen, well,
this chain is called Pyongyang and its structure is based on a network of
companies that collaborate with local companies through joint ventures in the
countries where they operate restaurants. That's by the way,
also serve to launder money from shady,
illegal activities that are absorbed within the income of those restaurants.
And one important point.
All of what we are telling you is not something from the past or anything like
that.
It is what is happening right now at the very point in time that you're watching
this video methods that are currently being used to finance Kim Jong-un's wimps,
including his ballistic missiles.
Meanwhile.
The U S government,
which is the main supporter and promoter of the sanctions against the regime in
Pyongyang has remained silence with its arms firmly crossed.
It almost seems that the Trump administration's strategy in North Korea has been
to let Kim do, as he bleeds,
it's both with his missiles and with the money he handles abroad with
negotiations like this, it's easy to succeed.
You just have to give everything they asked,
then claim you fix the relationship. Just like that.
The fact is friends that throughout this whole saga of evading sanctions,
there are some episodes that leave us stunned.
What if I told you that North Korea had managed to illegally export coal to its
bitter enemy its neighbor South Korea?
What if I told you that a shipment of luxury Mercedes Benz destined for North
Korea passed through the South Korean port of Busan with total impunity? Yes.
We're not getting to the regime elites managed to buy everything they want and
they don't even have to depend on China.
North Korea literally lives on the edge. Take a look.
[Inaudible].
Closer to the danger. Further from the damage.
We just told you.
That's in 2019 North Korea managed to export coal illegally to South Korea each
and every customs check failed and millions of dollars in North Korean coal
seeped through Pohang port, the recipient and a max,
a South Korean company that bought the coal from another company registered in
Hong Kong.
And it was transported by the very same ship that took several luxury.
Mercedes-Benz from Europe to North Korea.
[Inaudible].
In fact that ship registered as DN 55 Oh five,
unloaded the coal in South Korea on the return trip.
After dropping off Kim's high-end vehicles in the communist country.
[inaudible] We're talking about Mercedes vehicles bought by the North Korean
government for Kim Jong-un himself of the Mayback S 62 and the Mayback S
600 Pullman guard models. We are talking about the fully armored models.
Each one costs between $500,000 and $1.6 million. You know,
the story it's a matter of priority.
Well,
the fact is that these luxury cars traveled through six countries from Rotterdam
in the Netherlands,
where the cars left to Dalian in China on one ship and from there to sucker
Japan on a totally different boat.
And from there 2% in South Korea on yet another ship and Busan is where the cars
were transferred to the infamous freighter DN 55 Oh five from Busan.
They left for Nikon in Russia, and finally on the same ship,
they were unloaded in North Korea where the coal was supposedly loaded and ended
up in Pohang dizzying trip.
But the Mercedes got there in the end,
the luxury Mercedes that Kim Jong-un shows off at his summits with international
leaders, such as Donald Trump himself passed through countries,
allied with the United States, such as Japan, the Netherlands and South Korea,
without anyone actually noticing, of course,
it's like looking for a needle in a haystack,
North Koreans know this and take advantage of it.
It matters worse for tenants relations of the U S government with Russia and
above all with China,
with whom they continue an open trade war have kept these countries from
collaborating to punish historical enemies of the United States like North
Korea. In fact, in the last two years,
China has substantially relaxed the pressure.
It has been exerting against North Korea to prevent imports of sanction.
Products. We're talking about.
A lack of collaboration that has reached the point that huge North Korean cargo
and bulk carriers have been seen in Chinese waters off Joe Shan,
and one of the most heavily patrolled and militarized areas off the Chinese
coast.
An area where China.
Has Naval basis with frigates, destroyers, electronic surveillance vessels,
and radars of all kinds come on.
It is impossible to think that the Chinese government is not aware of these
movements. Isn't it?
So the question we should be asking is has Trump's foreign policy and
international sanctions serve to end North Korea's nuclear and ballistic missile
program? Well, the answer is definitely no.
Moreover, the sanctions are more poorest today than ever.
And as long as POM yang is able to escape them with such impunity and with so
much support the policy of negotiating,
the renunciation of nuclear weapons in exchange for lifting the sanctions does
not make much sense. Or in other words,
why would Kim Jong-un abandon either of his two star military programs?
If what he gets in return is relief from sanctions that he budges when and how
he wants at least to keep the regime satisfied.
If later on the people go hungry. Well,
obviously that is down to the misfortune and the workings of the evil American.
Empire. We see how events unfold.
But the truth is that North Korea is much stronger militarily today than it was
four years ago. And that is a reality that to a large extent,
has a lot to do with Trump's foreign policy in the white house.
But now it's your turn.
Do you think the way forward is to further deepen sanctions against North Korea?
Is there an alternative diplomacy to the economic blockade that could serve to
weaken the North Korean regime, leave your answers down in the comments?
So I really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit, like if you did,
don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. Also.
This channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
You learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice.
Check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite podcast.
[inaudible].